well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the new
statesman's deputy online editor rachel
kunliff and the chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace welcome
to you staying with us i know right
through until just before midnight so
let's check out the front pages then
starting with the financial times
they're covering the government's
decision to increase national insurance
contributions as a means of funding
social care the ft reporting the prime
minister will be looking to quell a
possible rebellion from within his own
conservative ranks in an effort to get
the legislation through parliament
the telegraph suggests the changes will
lead to the highest taxes since the
second world war the times with the same
focus tax burden will rise to the
highest in 70 years
the sun describes the move as bojo's
biggest gamble
similarly the guardian questions whether
the plan will deliver as the pm stakes
his reputation on the 12 billion pound
plan the daily mail pleads now make the
care worth the cost boris
the metro calls the government tax and
spend tories
and referring to the abandonment of the
pensions triple lock the star pictures
an elderly couple at a bus stop
remarking you don't break a manifesto
pledge for ages then two come along at
the same time
so let's get the thoughts then rachel
connelly and mark willis are here with
me now a mark big gamble big bill how um
as a conservative supporter are you
feeling tonight
pretty uncomfortable about this in in
various different ways i mean firstly
that question obviously reflected in
various the papers the idea of high
taxing tories uh it is not something i
think is particularly sensible the route
in particular that's been chosen i was
writing about this yesterday in fact
national insurance
is attacks that really ought not to
exist you know it's a giant con that's
been perpetrated on the british people
for decades the idea that there's this
insurance scheme and you pay into your
part and eventually you get out what
you've
paid in for
was true once upon a time it hasn't been
true for decades national insurance is
another form of income tax effectively
income tax the sequel and
now it's expensive and uh
as a result that you know that's one
reason why governments of all stripes
have found it easier to to mess with
national insurance with the result of
course that it applies to poorer workers
and younger workers disproportionately
in ways that we don't think are
acceptable for straight-up income tax
and rachel this levy will be
hypothecated to use the official phrase
or ring fenced as we might describe it
for this parliament at least but as the
daily mail uh discusses uh in there now
make the care worth the cost boris the
whole point of this is actually the
health service is the main focus for the
first few years
yes most of this money that was is being
billed as pay a little bit more
tax in order to save the social care
system isn't going into social care at
all it's going into the nhs uh so the
idea that this is the plan that we've
waited two years for since boris johnson
stood outside downing street on his
first day as prime minister and said we
have a plan to uh to to save social care
to fix the social care crisis that plan
doesn't seem to actually be fixing the
problem but it was meant to it seems to
be doing something else interesting as
well that later that same year 2019
boris johnson
went into a general election running on
a manifesto
of not increasing taxes not increasing
national insurance but of fixing the
social care system now a lot of
political commentators a lot of
westminster watchers were very keen to
find out what that social care plan was
that didn't involve raising taxes and
now we find two years later under the
cover of the pandemic which we all agree
was unprecedented but that that plan
didn't exist
and that what the government is doing as
mark said is increasing taxes increasing
taxes by 10 percent by the way which
none of the papers are
have have cited that bigger but it's
going up from 12 from for most people to
13.25 which is an increase a tax
increase of ten percent uh in order to
solve a problem that the government told
us two years ago it already had a plan
to solve yes and and do you think most
people will excuse his apparent untruths
mark with his phraseology a global
pandemic was on nobody's manifesto these
are unforeseeable times
well the thing is i think there's very
widespread understanding of the fact
that the pandemic
is is exceptional circumstances and it
in the circumstance of a natural
disaster a pandemic a major war
god god forbid something like that
people have some the way they're willing
to offer to politicians for the idea
that plans made in peace time as it were
um to a certain extent they're going to
be sideswiped by that but there is a
limit on on the amount of leeway they're
going to be willing to give and
particularly i think whether it's this
announcement whether it's another one
down the line um when it stops seeming
like an explanation and starts seeming
like an excuse by that point it will
have become too late and that that is
the risk you know any any politician
breaking a manifesto pledge has uh you
know it is taking a risk it's not that
it's you know these are not legally
binding documents for a very good reason
which is the governments do need to be
able to react to circumstance setting
aside whether i like this particular
policy or not um but you'll be very
careful with how you do it and how long
particularly if you want to stand for
election again yes and do you think um
many people will think actually this was
fairly politically astute where was all
the
the the tory ferrari that we saw in the
weekend papers for example as we look
ahead to the the vote uh on wednesday
but then actually entwining social care
with great support for the nhs and all
the hard work that people have done and
the great needs of people and that
massive backlog um that has helped do
you think get the keep keep those tories
who might complain about this quiet or
will we see dissent tomorrow rachel
i think a certain to a certain extent
barry johnson has covered his tracks
just because people don't realize that
you're scamming them doesn't mean that
it's the right thing to do i think the
fact that we have various papers citing
three cabinet ministers who spoke out
very strongly against these plans but
are unnamed cabinet sources and didn't
feel that uh it was
it was for them to resign or take a
stand over this issue just says
something about the level of integrity
among covenant ministers at the moment i
think uh conflating these issues and
saying it's about social care but it's
also about our nhs you want more money
for our nhs don't you you want more
money for the doctors and nurses don't
you it's a form of emotional blackmail
and it enables you to
break promises to make economic
illiterate decisions and we can come on
a bit later as to why a national
insurance rise is a particularly
abhorrent way of raising this money
under the cover of if anyone disagrees
with you it's because they don't like
the nhs or they don't like the doctors
and what and nurses who work in the nhs
which is very cynical and it it might
work as as mark said people don't seem
to realize that national insurance is a
form of income tax and this is a tax
rise on working people uh will he get
away with it probably just because i
think labour's very weak at the moment
and i think it's not like anyone else
had a different solution to social care
but again that doesn't make it right and
it doesn't make it any more justifiable
just because you might get away with it
yes and many people pointing out that
the high levels of taxation which is the
front page of the daily telegraph is
absolutely inevitable given our aging
population never mind the cost of the
pandemic uh but let's take a look at
that uh delhi telegraph front page mark
the words there of their associate
editor camilla tommeny we have just
witnessed the prime minister sound the
death knell for conservatism is that
fair i know david gawk a former cabinet
minister till he fell on the wrong side
of the the brexit debate suggested
actually uh yes certainly the tories
want to be the party of low taxation but
they are also fiscally conservative
which means balancing the books which is
what this policy does
well yes david gork i should say also a
conservative home columnist you can read
his contributions on our website
but you know this is
to a certain extent there's there's
always a little bit of a dilemma within
the history of conservatism the fact is
that
that divergence or that tension
sometimes as you say between balancing
the books and not wanting to raise taxes
too high but
we must face the fact they said this
could be become a really fundamental
issue for the cons as the party of low
taxes uh with a major opposition party
um the labour party seeking to get back
to being a potential party of government
traditionally the party probably of
higher taxes and it's all very well to
say oh well moving on to labour's turf
stealing that stealing their charity
well part of that
if it involves abandoning part of what
of you is essential to your own brand
that's a really fundamental problem
people want
a many people want a lower tax option of
course low taxes on just some
item of dogma they help to create growth
they help to create jobs they help to
also do something ethical which is even
more people's own money in their own
pocket for them to spend as they choose
well certainly that's been one of the
criticisms that if you go via the route
of national insurance it becomes a a tax
on jobs because employers also have to
to pay do they pass those costs on uh do
they pay people less and the other big
criticism of course is unfair in terms
of intergenerational uh divides and the
government has targeted pensioners via
if you are a working pensioner you now
need to pay national insurance under
these plans that dividends will also see
a tax credit increase and also the
triple lock suspended for one year which
is the subject of a rather humorous
daily mail a daily star rather rachel
well firstly i wanted to say thanks to
mark for mentioning that david gork also
writes columns he wrote one for the new
statesman recently pointing out
about social care and about how the way
we view fairness and unfairness with
this particular issue is is very very
strange we somehow think it is unfair to
ask people who have substantial assets
who perhaps own their own homes that
might be worth more than a million
pounds which is a fifth of all pensioner
households have assets were worth more
than a million pounds we think it's
unfair to ask them to contribute to
their own care posts but we think it is
perfectly fair to ask working age people
working age families who might be on the
minimum wage to increase the taxes that
they pay in order to make sure that
those wealthy people can stay in their
homes and pass that wealth onto their
children in the form of inheritances so
that
this is a the fact that this is an issue
that is uniting the left and the right
and all different strands of rebels on
the conservative party and beyond i i
think is is quite something the daily
start noting as you said that they're
also
making tweaks to the triple lock it's
going to be very very very slightly less
generous than it usually is it's going
to be a double lock instead still rising
by more than workers wages
apologies we're just running out of time
let's go to a small story that makes the
front page of the daily telegraph this
is the astrazeneca boss who cautions
against rushing to boosters um what do
we know from this uh this um well pricey
of an article mark
well we we we know a little as you say
it's just a it's a note from the front
of the telegraph but it does hinter that
kind of wider debate that i think is yet
to rage uh a little a little bit more
given everything else
that's been going on which is about the
balance of cost and benefit exactly
where these boosters are going to be
allocated for that matter
are they best being used in this country
or they're best being used to help
people in other countries who don't have
access to vaccines at all in some cases
yes and i suppose astrazeneca is one of
the big vaccines which has gone global
and certainly to some of the uh the
emerging countries as well um and
meantime of course uh this article
also points out that the chief medical
officers are deciding
on the wider implications of jabbing
youngsters young people
and the telegraph suggesting we could
hear as early as wednesday for that
rachel
yes it should be clear jabbing uh
teenagers with their parents consent uh
not just going into schools and and
doing it obviously this is a very key
issue at the moment because schools have
just gone back and there's a real worry
about infection levels rising in poorly
ventilated schools they have had all
summer to come up with a plan on this so
it's interesting they're only just doing
it now but the other interesting thing
about the astrazeneca boss warning is
pointing out that it's not just about
the the amount of vaccines it's also
about time and resources and making sure
that people get other healthcare
services that they need flu jabs or
cancer screenings and that all of the uh
nhs effort isn't used up on a booster
rollout which may make us feel safer but
might not have the the widespread
benefits that people would hope that it
would
to rush you again i do apologize rachel
khan left mark wallace thank you both
very much indeed